Olha essa descoberta aqui que está
mudando tudo que a gente achava sobre
envelhecimento. Você acha que músculos
fortes dependem só de academia e
proteína? Pois é, agora sabemos que o
intestino também comanda esse jogo.
Pesquisadores descobriram que certas
bactérias do intestino, principalmente
lactobacidos Johnson e Reutere, aumentam
diretamente a força e a massa muscular.
Em estudos, animais idosos que receberam
essas bactérias tiveram aumento de até
157%
no peso muscular e fibras musculares
visivelmente maiores. Além disso,
melhorou coordenação, resistência e caiu
a inflamação crônica. Então, veja bem,
não é só sobre malhar pesado, é sobre
ter um intestino saudável. Essas
bactérias literalmente conversam com os
músculos, mandam sinais de crescimento,
reduz inflamação. É o eixo intestino
músculo funcionando a favor da
longevidade. Então, da próxima vez que
você pensar envelhecer forte, lembra,
cuida o intestino, probiótico de
qualidade, fermentados, fibras, isso
tudo pode estar protegendo seus músculos
mais do que você imagina. Yeah.